[Music]
and rent for your rent news read for
rent submitted by a mustard or ketchup
mustard both yeah mayonnaise I love
mayonnaise well for me I like sticking
to what the question was
Oh relish Miracle Whip is okay cuz it's
sweeter no I like all that stuff you
work from the south you like it I came
up with a new artichoke dip type Mayo
it's pretty good hey Olli
yeah a new home buying service offers to
give you the down payment with one
simple catch they'll give you the down
baby they give you the down payment you
have to be a prostitute for them here's
a sexual in nature not sexual but you're
just show titties no yes but with your
home huh suit your home at the far your
home like Airbnb exactly for how long no
no Airbnb
yeah so I guess I wouldn't mind it if
it's legal Oh what are you talking about
[Laughter]
you can go that quickly too
I wouldn't mind if my home was a brothel
if it was legal yeah I'm picturing it's
more like a dormitory so I have my
private space and I'm not thinking a
single-family residence so if someone's
gonna pay the down payment for that and
I own it when everything's paid off PAMP
you got to repaint the whole room over
oh yeah I think about that twice he's
like I don't want to do that
he's like oh yeah I don't want to do
that work cuz he can turn on the
backlight in there it'll get nuts in
there look like your feet literally but
on a brighter note there's always house
guests every day that you could get to
know the kind of guy who picks up a
hooker because you want to get to know
her tell me your story and she's like
I'm getting out of the car is [ __ ]
weird I'd rather just you just saying
you want to put it in my blood I come
here for that I came I came for your
story yeah tell me your story means like
are the inside handles of my door gonna
work that's what he gets scary well
anyways back to this thing though so uh
this woman this 29 year old entrepreneur
her name is you fun zing and this is
what she looked like like a Chinese lady
she started up a what's your hiding in
the closet yeah we had those bed sheets
she oh yeah we do I don't know it looks
like a very familiar pattern so as she's
standing in her spare bedroom of her
home she started up this company called
Las iam in Seattle and so what this
company is is they front up to fifty
thousand dollars for a down payment on a
home no no no not in San Fran yeah
not in California oh I didn't see I
don't think it's enough baby oh it's in
Seattle well she started her company in
Seattle
she's like slowly expanding to different
but that's one of the most expensive
places is it Seattle her startup what it
is is they front the down payment money
you still have to go with a different
lender for your actual your actual
mortgage like to finance your mortgage
but the way this thing works is if they
front you the down payment you have to
agree to rent out a spare room in your
in your home to Airbnb for one two three
years and the amount of money that they
make out of the Airbnb will go to that
company to pay off the duchies the
collateral is that you're gonna for sure
in this room out for three years
I guess and that's 50 G's they're making
out with this thing no it's actually
more so exactly an example so here is an
example of a room where they rented out
for $150 a night and then assuming a
seventy five percent occupancy rates
excluding eight free days that the
homeroom owner gets to themselves like
for that room excluding all that it's
two hundred sixty eight days a year
times three years is 120 thousand six
hundred over three years and then the
way they divide that it will go thirty
six thousand one hundred and eighty will
go to the homeowner so the portion that
they get to keep as long as they also
they get to make money too yeah that's a
lot of math yeah and then the other
break is they get their fifty thousand
that they the repayment and then lofty
um gains thirty four thousand four well
that's that's cool rest or whatever kind
of okay yeah so that's the way it works
out yeah so it's 120 but then the 50
goes back to the loan which it pays
itself off but then on top of that the
homeowner gets some extra income for a
minute is lost down so they get almost
like a hundred G's doing this yeah
that's pretty cool no yeah so they're
saying that this is geared more for
people that you know they can't save
enough or you know they're really tight
on money and they can't save enough to
have a down payment on a home well 50
G's helps out like for example like our
friend and in Christianity just got a
new path and then like if they had an
extra 50 G's that just means they're 10
to 15 minutes closer to work so when
they're like buying homes like yeah
they're trying to like live within
limits but then especially living like a
metropolitan like LA every ten minutes
you have to add almost like 50 to 100
grand onto the home price so it can
really help out and really widen your
options you might not be the full
downpayment but just to give you guys a
perspective of how much homes are here
average is anywhere from 600 to 800
thousand and way more like a regular
[ __ ] for like the suburbs
that's for a house with a cage on your
windows pretty much yeah that's that's
average for outskirts suburb LA but then
in nurse-like not inner-city but then
like Westside or the more expensive
parts I think it's at least a mill or
like for those average homes yeah so
what and you have to put down 20 to 30%
at least 20% that's hundreds of
thousands of dollars man we're in Texas
we get a $200,000 home for like you know
it's really really really nice yeah well
a down payment is the whole price of a
home in Texas yeah Texas you get it on
indoor pool you get a [ __ ] butler
service like for like 400 G's it's crazy
yeah indoor racetrack helipad you don't
it doesn't come with a helicopter will
you get it although I do love how we all
act like helipads are so Swank we're
like how [ __ ] much money is it to
make a hell of it and maintain it like
think about that if you have a yard
you just [ __ ] throw a small in the
circle then paint HHR you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what a waste of a backyard I
would as a white trash piece of [ __ ]
myself
love to have a helipad and never use it
I never use it but I painted I got a
helipad and I put down I put that on the
amenities on my list of things it's like
got a [ __ ] helipad that's gonna cop
there but a helipad you figure out your
helicopter I got a helipad done pretty
soon we're gonna have flying taxis
anyway so right there there you go there
you go yeah sure would you get in a
flying taxi with no driver cuz I've been
reading with this [ __ ] there's no driver
oh yeah there drone taxis
yeah there's single people's would you
get in that rut immediately I'm not a
first user but after few years I would
why wouldn't you put a monkey in there
about that cuz I like monkeys okay like
put a monkey in a [ __ ] spacesuit I'd
be like no get him out of there I
wouldn't
- either too cute for that yeah what
animal would you put another I put like
a [ __ ] squirrel in there he would
have like monkeys I feel like even a
monkey in spaces and oats go on a scroll
would have no [ __ ] idea we have no
clue gotta get like scorpions or
centipedes or something that you don't
want and just get a big bag full of them
and put it in the see if they would
survive much they like go off to Mars
and then they multiply there and they
turn it to something from the Martian
yeah and if they [ __ ] want revenge
and they come back at us all evolving
[ __ ] oh hey did the enemy or ghost enemy
[ __ ] now we have superheroes yeah we'll
have you guys been thinking of my own
any property I knew you owned property a
house do you own any I love saying uh
I'm purchasing property like I'm a
[ __ ] like I'm on cops and I'm doing
and like it like I'm I got a ride-along
like oh yeah well all these properties
are usually in with Butch alcohol sure
you're like I don't know who says
properties this much I don't know I
don't it's like you're gonna buy a house
usually yeah that's nice I like have a
house I like saying the word property is
fun in your mouth but it also feels like
you're like they more balling really are
like hey I own property how much
property is one house it's more yeah
yeah no we don't have a house um thanks
to California yeah that's crazy choice
to stay well sure but the whole industry
is here I mean yes we left here you know
I just want land I don't get what doubt
about a house just give me like dirt
grass and a nice view
lots of it in California or outside go
anywhere go to River something nice what
would you do with the land I don't know
I just want it and then I'll start
becoming uni I mean creative once once
it's there maybe build a mud hut I've
been watching primitive technology and
he uses the land to build everything so
you know do something like that
you build a mud hut a tunnel and then
you're bored [ __ ] dude you're
the most bored dude I've ever met
okay I'll show you primitive technology
yeah it'll make it'll change your life
feel like Steve is the kind of gather
laughs damn I didn't know it could be
like this he uses the earth and he
builds everything no I'm like no this is
like when people were like oh yeah like
we've got a clay fire pizza oven and I'm
like it just tastes this [ __ ] saying
the same thing good for you I'm glad
people yeah was it that the most
interest thing you've ever heard and
your whole entire life I don't even know
what you guys just talked about but
anyways please subscribe for more random
videos more funny content and more
hahaha poo poo in your pants nah go
ahead subscribe and for more videos
right now